[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING] [CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: OK, hello, everybody.
We'll get started.
So just recapping what we did
in the last lecture on Tuesday,
it was the second part
of a two-lecture sequence
on the hierarchy theorems
for time and space
and using the hierarchy
theorems to show
that there is a problem,
which is intractable,
that's provably outside
of polynomial time.
And that was this equivalence
problem for regular expressions
with exponentiation.
And then we had a short
discussion about oracles
and the possibility that similar
methods might be used to show
that satisfiability
is outside of P,
which would then of course
solve the P versus NP problem
and argue that it seems unlikely
this kind of a meta theorem--
not a well-defined notion--
but it seems unlikely
that the methods that
were used for proving the
intractability of equivalence
of regular expressions
with explanation
could be used to solve
P versus NP, at least
the diagonalization method in a
pure form, whatever that means,
that's not going to be enough.
So today, we're going to
shift gears again, begin
a somewhat different
topic, which is really
going to be our,
again, a few lectures
on probabilistic computation,
which is going to round out
the semester for us.
And we're going to
start by talking
about a different model
of computation which
allows for probabilism
in the measuring
the amount of probabilism
we're measuring
the probabilities allowing for
probabilism in the computation
defined an associated
complexity class--
this class BPP-- and then start
the discussion of an example
about something called
branching programs.
OK, so with that in mind--
so we're going to
start off by defining
the notion of a Probabilistic
Turing Machine or PTM.
The Probabilistic
Turing Machine is
a lot like the way
we have thought
about not deterministic
Turing machines in that it's
a kind of a machine that
can have multiple choices,
multiple ways to go
in its computation.
So there's not just going to
be a fixed deterministic path
of its computation,
but there's going
to be a tree of possibilities.
And for our
purposes, we're going
to limit the
branching in that tree
to be either a step
of the computation
where there's no
branching, where
it's a deterministic
step, as shown over here.
So every step of the way leads
uniquely to the next step.
Or there might be some
steps which have a choice.
And we're only going to
allow for these purposes
to keep life simple,
having only a choice
among two possibilities.
And we'll associate
to that the notion
of a probability that each
choice will have a 50-50 chance
of getting taken.
And this kind of corresponds
with the way some of us
or some of you think about
non-determinism, which
is not exactly right
up until this point,
is that the machine is kind
of taking a random branch.
Really, we don't think
about it randomly until now.
Now we're going to
think about the machine
as actually picking a
random choice among all
the different branches
that it could make
and picking that choice
uniformly by flipping
a coin every time it has an
option of which way to go.
Now you could define--
I'm getting a question here--
a machine that has several
different ways to--
more than two ways to go.
And then you would need
to have a three-way coin,
a four-way coin, and so on.
And you could define it
all that way as well.
But it doesn't end up giving you
anything different or anything
interesting or new for
the kinds of things
we're going to be discussing.
And it's just
going to be simpler
to keep the discussion
limited to the case
where the machine can only
have two possibilities if it's
going to be having a choice
at all or just one possibility
when there's no choice.
OK, so now, we're
going to have to talk
about the probability
of the machine
taking some branch
of its computation.
So you imagine here, here
is the same computation tree
that we've seen
before in the case
of ordinary
non-deterministic machines,
where you have M on w.
There could be several
different ways to go.
And there might be
some particular branch.
But now, we want to talk
about the probability
that the machine actually
ends up picking that branch.
And it's going to be when we
talk about the machine having
a choice of ways
to go, we're going
to associate that
with a coin flip.
So we're going to call
that a coin flip step
when the machine has a
possibility of ways to go.
And so on a particular
branch, the probability
of that branch occurring
is going to be 1 over 2
to the number of coin flip
states on that branch.
and the reason for--
I mean, this is kind of the
definition that makes sense
in that if you imagine looking
at the computation tree here--
and here is the branch that
we're focusing on of interest--
every time there's a
coin flip on that branch,
there's a 50-50 chance of
taking a different branch
or staying on that branch.
So the more coin flips there
are on some particular branch,
the less likely
that branch would
be the one that the machine
actually ends up taking.
And so it's going to be 1 over
2 to the number of coin flips.
And that's the way
we're defining it.
Now once we have that
notion, we can also
talk about the probability
that the machine ends up
accepting because as before,
each of these branches
is going to end up at an
accept state or reject state,
thinking about this only
in terms of deciders.
And the probability of
the machine accepting here
is just going to be the
sum over all probabilities
of the branches that
end up accepting.
So just add up all of those
probabilities of a branch
leading to an accept, and
we'll call that the probability
that the machine
accepts its input.
And the probability
that the machine rejects
is going to be 1
minus the probability
that it accepts because the
machine, on every branch,
is either going to do
one or the other, OK?
Now if you're thinking
about a particular language
that the machine is
trying to decide,
this probabilistic machine
now is trying to decide,
on each input, some of the
branches of the machine
may give the correct answer.
They're going to accept when
the input is in the language.
Other branches may
give the wrong answer.
They may reject when the input
is in the language and vise
versa.
So there's going to be
a possibility of error
now in the machine in
any particular branch.
It might actually
give the wrong answer.
And what we're going
to say is bound
that error over all
possible inputs,
and we'll say that the
machine for any epsilon
greater than or
equal to 0, we will
say that the machine decides the
language with error probability
epsilon if that's the
worst that can possibly
happen if, for every
input, the machine gives
the wrong answer with
probability at most epsilon.
Equivalently, if you like to
spell it out a little bit more,
a little differently,
for strings
that are in the
language, the probability
that the machine
rejects that input
is going to be at most epsilon.
And for strings in the
language the probability
for strings not in the language,
the probability that accepts
is at most epsilon.
So again, this is the machine
doing the thing that it's not
supposed to be doing.
For things in the
language, it should
be rejecting very rarely.
For things not in
the language, it
should be accepting very rarely.
And that's what this bound
is doing for you, OK?
So let's just see.
So we'll talk about-- so I'm
getting some questions here
about--
so let me just look at these.
One second here.
Yeah, so probability 0--
so there's a possibility
that the machine
might have a probability
0, say, of accepting.
That means there are no
branches that end up accepting
or probability 0 of rejecting.
There were no
rejecting branches.
I think we're going
to talk in a minute
about the connection
between this
and the standard notion of NP.
So just hold off on
that for a second.
Also, what about the
possibility that the machine
is being a decider or running
in a certain amount of time?
So we will look at time-bounded
machines in a second
on the next slide or two,
talking about machines
that run in polynomial time.
So that means all
branches have to halt
within some polynomial
number of steps.
So that's where we're going.
But for the time
being, we're the only
looking at deciders,
where the machine has
to hold on every branch.
But some branches might
run for a long time.
But for now, we're not going to
be thinking about machines that
have branches that run forever.
All of our machines
are deciders,
so they hold on every branch.
See, is there
anything else here?
No.
So why don't I move on?
So let's define now
the class BPP using
this notion of a
probabilistic Turing
machine, which is now going to
be running in polynomial time.
So BPP is going to be another
one of this complexity
classes, a collection
of languages, like P,
and NP, and PSPACE, and so on.
But it's going to
be now associated
with the capabilities of
these probabilistic machines,
the kinds of languages
that they can do.
So we'll say, the class BPP
is the set of languages, A,
that there's some probabilistic
polynomial time Turing
machines, so all branches
have to hold within--
into the k for some k.
So some polynomial time
probabilistic Turing machine
decides A with error
possibility, at most, 1/3.
So in other words,
when it's accepting
for strings in the
language, the machine
has to reject
with, at most, 1/3.
So it's saying it equivalently.
For strings in the
language, it has
to accept with 2/3 probability.
And for strings not
in the language,
it has to reject
with 2/3 probability,
at least, in both cases.
OK.
Somehow, I ended up with--
I didn't check my
animation here.
But OK, that's fine.
So there is a--
now if you look at the 1/3
here in the definition,
it seems strange to
define a complexity
class in terms of some
arbitrary content like 1/3.
Why didn't we use 1/4 or
1/10 in the definition of BPP
and say the machine has to
get have an error with at most
1/10 or 1/100?
Well, it doesn't matter.
And that's the point
of this next statement
called the amplification
lemma, which
says that you can always--
if you have a machine
that's running
in a certain
polynomial time that's
running with a certain error,
which is, at most, 1/2.
If you have an error
1/2, it's not interesting
because the machine could just
flip a coin for every input,
and it could get the right
answer with probability of 1/2.
So probability 1/2
is not interesting.
You have to have probability
strictly less than 1/2
for the machine to actually
be doing something that's
meaningful about that language.
So if you have a probabilistic
Turing machine that has error,
let's say, epsilon 1,
which is, at most, 1/2--
which is less than
1/2, then you can
convert that to any
error probability
you want for some
other polynomial time
probabilistic Turing machine.
So you can make that error,
which maybe starts out as 1/3,
and you can drive that error
down to 1 over a googol.
And seriously, you
can really make
the error extremely,
extremely small
using a very simple procedure.
And that's simply this--
so if you're starting
out with a machine that
has an error
possibility of 1/3, say,
so that means 2/3
of the time it's
going to get the right answer,
and, at most, 1/3 of the time--
the least 2/3 of the time,
the right answer, at most,
1/3 of the time, the
incorrect answer,
whether that's
accepting or rejecting.
And now you want to
get that answer down
to be something much-- that
error down to something
much smaller.
The idea is, you're going
to take that machine,
and you're going to
run it multiple times
with independent runs, if you
want to think about it more
formally speaking.
But it's intuitive.
You're just going to run the
machine, tossing your coins.
Instead of just
running it once, you're
going to run the machine 100
times or a million times.
But you can do it at just,
say, it's a constant factor.
And even 1,000
times is going to be
enough to increase your
confidence in the result
tremendously because if you
run the machine 1,000 times,
and 600 of those times, the
machine accepts, and 400
of the times, the
machine rejects,
it's very powerful
evidence that this machine
is biased toward
accepting, that it's
accepting most of the time.
So if it had an error
probability, at most,
1/3, the probability
that you're seeing
it accept 600 times when,
really, 2/3 of the time,
it's rejecting overall,
is extremely unlikely.
And you can calculate that--
which we're not going
to bother to do,
but it's a routine
probability calculation--
to show that the
probability that if you
run it a whole bunch of times,
and you see the majority coming
up, which is not the right
answer, the probability of that
is extremely small.
So I'm not saying
that very clearly.
But the method here
is you're going
to take your original machine,
which has error probability 1/3
or whatever it is--
maybe has error probability 49%.
And you run it for a
large number of times.
And then you take
the majority vote.
And you're sampling the
outcomes of this machine.
And if you take enough samples,
it's overwhelmingly likely--
since you're just
doing them uniformly--
you're taking those
samples uniformly,
it's overwhelmingly
likely that you're
going to be seeing the
predominant one come up
more often.
And exactly what
that right value is,
we're not going to
bother to calculate.
But that's something that, I
will refer you to the textbook,
or this is the
kind of thing that
comes up in any elementary
probability book
and sort of very intuitive.
So I don't want
to spend the time
and do that calculation, which
is not all that interesting.
OK, so just one quick question
here that I'm getting--
what happens if you
bound-- if the error is
greater than a half?
I don't think that because
we're bounding the error,
so we're not saying the
error actually is one, like,
60% on everything because
then if you knew the error was
60% guaranteed, you can always
just flip your answer around
and get your error to be 40%.
But I'm saying the error's
at most whatever epsilon is.
And so if you're saying
the error is, at most, 60%,
it doesn't tell you anything.
OK.
Another question is, does
the amplification lemma also
justify that the choice of model
with binary branching choices
is equivalent to any other?
Perhaps, you could say that
because you can change those.
If you had three-way
branching, you
can simulate that with two-way
branching to any accuracy
that you want.
You're not going to
get it down to zero,
but you're going to
get it very close.
So maybe it's the
amplification lemma.
Maybe it's, yeah,
sort of all related.
OK, let's move on.
So the way that it's helpful
to think about this class,
let's contrast it
with the other model
of non-deterministic
computation that we
have is non-determinism, is NP.
So non-deterministic,
the model of
non-deterministic
polynomial time computation
was NP, the other class.
And so the way--
I think one way to
look at or think
about non-determinism
in the case of NP
is, for strings in the language
for your NP Turing machine,
there's at least one
accepting branch.
So I'm indicating the
accepting ones in green
and the non-accepting one,
the rejecting branches in red.
So you could have almost all
of the branches be rejecting
branches for strings
in the language
as long as there is at
least one accepting branch.
That's just the way
non-determinism works.
The accepting branch
overrules all of the others.
It's only when you're
not in the language
that all of the branches turn
out to have to be rejecting.
That's when the rejecting
has no accepting branch
to overrule it.
But the situation for BPP
is a little different--
is different.
There, it's kind of
the majority rules.
So in the case for
strings in the language,
you need to have a large--
or the overwhelming
majority of the branches
have to be accepting.
And for strings not
in the language,
the overwhelming majority
have to be rejected.
What you're not going to
allow in the case of BPP
is kind of an in-between
state where it's sort of 50-50
or very, very close to 50-50.
Those kinds of
machines don't qualify
as designing a language in BPP.
They always have to
lean one way or lean
the other way for every input.
Otherwise, you won't be able
to do the amplification.
So you need to have
some bias away from half
in accepting or rejecting.
So let me-- so I was going
to ask a check-in, I think,
at this point.
Yes, let's.
So just thinking about
BPP, I hope I was clear.
So if there's
questions about that,
I think I've somehow didn't--
I'm not sure I described
it totally well here.
So I'm going to ask a
few questions about BPP.
But if you have any questions
for me first, go ahead.
OK, why don't we just
run the check-in?
Let me launch this, and
then I can answer questions
as you're asking.
Did I start that?
Yeah.
OK, so you have to check all of
these that you think are true.
Can you think of
non-deterministic Turing
machines as try all branches at
once and get the right answer?
And BP gets only one branch?
No.
I would say a
little differently.
I would say, I would
think of non-determinism
as you can still
just try one branch,
but you always
guess the right one.
So there's some sort
of magical power
that allows you always to guess
the right answer if there's
a right guess If
you're in the language.
In the case of BPP,
you're going to be picking
a random branch no matter what.
And you know that
the random branch
is likely to give the right
answer but not guaranteed.
And the amplification
lemma tells you
you can arrange
things so that it's
extremely likely that the
random branch is going
to give you the right answer.
OK, let's see.
How we doing on
our check-in here?
Got a lot of support
for all candidates.
And I'll give you another--
a little bit of time
here because there's
a bunch of questions.
It's almost like four
check-ins at once.
But we have two more real
check-ins coming later.
OK, so why don't we
come and let's give it
another 10 seconds, and
then I'm going to stop.
Closing down-- 1, 2, 3, close.
OK, so we've got a
lot of support here.
And in fact that's good
because all of them are true.
Some of them are easier
to see than others.
So first of all, c is very
easy to see because that's
going to be a machine that
has the correct answer all
of the time.
So that's error
probability zero on both
accepting and rejecting.
This is a little harder.
D is a little bit harder
to see that it's in PSPACE.
But you could calculate
for every branch
what its probability is.
And you can just go
through all the branches
and add up all those
probabilities in a PSPACE
machine.
So you have to think
about it a little bit.
But d is not too
hard to see either.
Closure under complement-- if
you just take your BPP machine
and you flip the answer on
every branch, that's typically
doesn't work in ordinary
non-determinism,
but it does work
here because it's
going to change a
bias toward accepting
into a bias toward
rejecting and vice versa.
So BPP is closed
under complement.
And closure under a union--
it kind of follows from
the amplification lemma.
As long as you can make the
probability extremely small,
then you can just run the
two different machines.
And even though
the they each may
make a mistake
cumulatively, the total,
the probability that each one
of them-- that either of them
will make a mistake
is still small.
And so you can just
run the two machines
and take the or of the
responses that they get,
and it's still very
likely to give you
the right answer for the union.
OK, let's continue.
So what I'm going to do now for
the rest of the lecture is--
and it's actually
going to spill over
into the lecture
after Thanksgiving
because this is
going to introduce
an important method for us--
is to look at an example
of a problem that's in BPP.
I love to teach things
by using examples,
and so this is a
very good example
because it has a
lot of meat to it.
And it's a very
interesting example.
In general, proving things in
BPP, which are not trivially
there because
they're already in P,
they tend to be
somewhat more involved
than some of the other
algorithms we've seen.
So there are no simple
examples of problems in BPP
which are not already in P.
So this is one
example that we're
going to go through of
a problem in BPP that's
not known to be in P. Of course,
things could collapse down,
but as far as we know,
this language is not in P.
So let's see what
the language is.
It has to do with these things
called branching programs.
The branching program is a
structure that looks like this.
So let's understand
what the pieces are.
First of all, it's
a directed graph.
And we're not going to allow--
there are no cycles
allowed in this graph.
It's a directed acyclic graph--
so no loops allowed.
And the nodes are
in two categories.
There are query nodes, which are
labeled with a variable letter,
and output nodes, which
are labeled either 0 or 1.
And lastly, one of the
query nodes is going to be--
or one of the nodes is going to
be designated as a start, OK?
And so what you do is, the way--
this is a model of computation.
And the way we actually use
a branching program is we
have some assignment
to the variables.
That's going to be the input.
So you take all
of the variables.
There are three
variables in this case--
x1, x2, and x3.
You give them some
truth assignment.
So let's say, zero's a 1.
And so x1 is 0.
x1 is 1, or whatever.
And once you have
the truth assignment,
you start at the start variable,
and you look at its label.
And you see what value the input
has assigned to that variable.
So if x1 is assigned
a 1, you're going
to follow down the 1 branch.
If it assigned a 0, you
go down the 0 branch.
And then when you get
down to the next node,
that's another
variable that you're
going to have to query
depending upon what the input
assignment is.
And you're just going to
continue that process.
Because there are
no cycles, you're
going to end up at one
of the output nodes
because all of the
variable nodes--
all the query nodes
have two outgoing edges,
one labeled 0 and one labeled 1.
So you're going to eventually
end up at an output node,
and that's going
to be the output
of the branching program.
So let's do a quick example.
So if x1 is 1, x2
is 0, and x3 is 1--
so again, we start at
the start variable--
the start node that has the
indicated with the arrow
coming in from nowhere.
So you're going to start
at the nose labeled x1.
So you have to look and see,
what is x1 in the input?
It's a 1.
So you're going to
follow down the 1 branch.
Now you see the next node.
Oh, that's an x3.
We see, what's x3 in
the input? x3 is a 1.
So go down to 1 branch again.
Now we have an x2 node.
Take a look at the
input. x2 is a 0.
We follow the 0 branch.
Now, you're at an output
branch, an output node.
So that's a 0, and that's the
output of this computation.
So writing it this way
and thinking about it
as a Boolean function which
maps strings of zeros and ones,
we have f of 101 representing
those that assignment.
That equals 0.
That was the output.
And that's the output
of this computation, OK?
So important to understand.
We're going to
spend a lot of time
talking about branching
programs-- so critical
to understand this model.
I think it's fairly simple.
But if you didn't
get it, please ask.
We can easily correct up any
misunderstanding at this point.
It's not exactly
the same as a DFA.
DFAs, for one thing, can
take inputs of any length.
This has inputs of
some particular length,
where the branching program has
some fixed number of variables.
This one has three.
So this only takes
inputs of length 3.
So there's maybe some connection
to thinking of these as states
and so on, but it's
a different model.
So now, we'll say that
two branching programs--
OK, let me just ask
one more question.
Not all nodes need
to be used, right?
Yeah, I mean, there's
no requirement
that all nodes need to be used.
And there even could
be inaccessible nodes.
I'm not preventing that.
That could be OK.
So on the particular
branch, certainly, you're
not going to-- when
you're executing
this branching
program on an input,
obviously, certainly,
you're going
to have a path that's
going to only use
some part of the tree,
a part of the graph.
But there might be some
paths that can never occur.
So if you went down x equal to
1 here, and then x3 was 0, now,
you're re-reading x1, so you
wouldn't go down this branch
unless you--
I think all of the branches
in this particular branching
program could get used.
But I didn't check that,
so maybe I'm wrong.
OK, so let's continue.
Two branching programs
may or may not
compute the same function.
We'll say they're
equivalent if they do.
Now two branching
programs can be equivalent
even though they
superficially look different
from one another.
And we're interested in the
computational problem of,
given two of these
branching programs,
do they compute
the same function?
In other words, do they
always give the same answer
on the setting of the input?
So we'll define the
associated language.
Equivalence problem
for branching programs
says that you're given two
of these branching programs,
and they're equivalent
to be in the language.
We're going to sometimes
write equivalents
using the mathematical notation
of the three-lined equals sign,
equivalence sign.
OK, that means a computer
saying-- they always
give the same answer.
Now that problem turns
out to be coNP-complete,
as I've asked you to show
on your homework, I believe.
This is not a super
hard reduction.
And coNP complete, by the
way, is the complement
of an NP-complete problem.
Or equivalently, it's a problem
to which all coNP problems are
polynomial time-reducible,
and it's in coNP.
So this is coNP-complete,
and that's for you to show.
But that has an important
significance for us
right now because if--
looking at the question of
whether this problem is in BPP,
the fact that it's
coNP-complete suggests
that the answer is no because if
a coNP-complete or NP-complete
problem more in BPP because
everything else in NP or coNP
is reducible to that problem,
then all of those NP or coNP
problems would be in BPP
for exactly the same reason
that we've seen before.
And that's not
known to be the case
and not believed to be the case.
So we don't expect that
coNP-complete problem
is going to be in BPP.
That would be an amazing
and surprising result.
So because I hope I made it
clear in my previous discussion
that the BPP, from a
practical standpoint,
is very close to being like P
because you can make the error
probability of the machine
so incredibly low that it's
a comparable--
if you run the machine
and the error probability
is like 1 over googol, then
it's sort of even greater
than the probability
that some alpha particle
came in and flipped the
value of some internal memory
cell in your computation.
So if you have an extremely
low error probability,
it's pretty good from
a practical standpoint.
So it would be amazing if NP
problems were solvable in BPP.
So this is not
the language we're
going to use as our example.
We're going to look at a
related, restricted version
of this problem
about equivalence
for branching programs.
And that, I'm going to
introduce right now.
OK, any questions here?
I don't see any questions.
I'm fading out.
OK, so let's move on.
So we're going to talk
about branching programs
that are what are
called read-once,
read-once branching programs.
And those are simply
branching programs
that are not allowed to
reread an input that they've
previously read.
So for example, is
this branching program
a read-once branching program?
No.
This branching program is not
a read-once branching program
because you can
find a path that's
going to cause you to read the
same variable more than once.
So it's not going
to be a read-once.
So over here, it's not read-once
because there's two occurrences
of an x1 on the same branch.
Now you might ask,
why would anybody
want to do that because you've
already read the value of x1?
Well, in the case of this
particular branching program,
there might be a
value because you
could have got to this x1 branch
by going this way or that way.
But that's a separate question.
If we restrict our attention to
read-once branching programs,
then the problem of
testing equivalence
becomes very different
in character.
And in fact, we're going to
give a probabilistic algorithm--
a BPP algorithm to
solve that problem.
So the equivalence problem for
read-once branching programs,
which are not allowed
to reread variables
on any path, that's
interestingly
going to be solvable with a
probabilistic polynomial time
algorithm with a small
error probability.
So I'm going to
run a check-in now.
But let's make sure we're
all together on this.
So I've got a good
question here.
Can every Boolean
function be described
by a branching program?
Yes.
That's an easy exercise.
But you can make--
branching programs are--
they may be a large,
but you can describe
any Boolean function
with some branching program.
That's not hard to show.
Other question--
are we all together
on understanding
what read-once means,
and branching programs,
and all that stuff?
This is a good time
to ask if you're not.
OK, so let's do the check-in.
So as I pointed
out, we will show
that the equivalence for
read-once branching programs
is solvable in BPP.
Can we use that to solve the
general case for branching
programs by converting
general branching programs
to read-once branching
programs and then
running the read-once test?
So what do you think?
OK, I'm seeing a lot of
correct answers here.
So let's wrap this
one up quickly.
So another 10 seconds, please.
OK?
Are we all ready?
1, 2, 3, closing.
All right, yes.
Most of you have
answered correctly.
Well, answer A is not a very
good answer because we already
commented on the previous
slide that we don't know
how to do the
general case in BPP,
so it would be kind of
surprising if, right here, I'm
saying, yes, we could do it
by using the restricted case.
So I think a better
answer would be
to one of the no's,
but as I did comment,
you can always convert--
you can always do any
Boolean function with a--
well, maybe I didn't say it for
read-once branching programs.
But even read-once
branching programs
can compute any
Boolean function.
So the conversion is
possible but, in general,
will not be polynomial time.
And if you imagine even trying
to do the conversion over here,
you could convert this
branching program to read-once,
but you'd have to
basically separate the two.
You know, instead
of rereading the x1,
you could remember
that x1 value.
But then you would not be-- you
couldn't converge over here.
You'd have to keep those two
threads of the-- those two
branches of the
computation apart--
those two paths apart
from one another.
And already, the
branching program
would start to increase
in size by doing that.
And so, in general,
converting is possible,
but it requires a big
increase in the size.
And then it will not allow
a polynomial time algorithm
anymore, even in the
probabilistic case.
OK, so now, let's start
to look at the possibility
of showing that this equivalence
problem is solvable in BPP.
And it's going to take us in
a kind of a strange direction,
but let's try to get our
intuition going first
by doing something which seems
like the most obvious approach.
So here, so we're going to
give an algorithm now, which
is going to be an attempt.
This is not going to work,
but nevertheless, it's
going to have the germ of the
right idea or not the germ
but the beginning of the
right way to think about it.
So here are the two
read-once branching programs,
B,1 and B,2.
And I want to see,
do they compute
the same function or not?
So one thing you
might try is just
running them on a bunch of
randomly selected assignments
or inputs.
So you can just take two
random input assignments.
Just take x1, flip a
coin to say it's 1 or 0.
Do the same for x2 and so on.
Then you get some
input assignment.
You run the two branching
programs on that assignment.
And maybe that
doesn't give-- even
if they agree, it doesn't
give you a lot of confidence
that you get the right answer,
that they're really equivalent.
So you do it 100
times, whatever--
some number of times.
And of course, if
they ever disagree
on one of those
assignments, then you
know they're not equivalent,
and you can immediately reject.
But what I'd like
to say is if they
agree on those 100 tries or
those 100 assignments there,
then they are, at least
I haven't found a place
where they disagree,
so I'm going
to say that they're equivalent.
Is that a reasonable
thing to do?
Well, it might be.
It depends on k.
So the critical thing
is, what value of k
should you pick which is
going to be big enough
to allow us to draw the
conclusion that if you run it
for k times, and you
never see a difference,
then you can conclude,
with good confidence,
that the two branching programs
are equivalent because you
tried to look for a difference,
and you never found one.
Well, the thing is that k is
going to have to be pretty big.
So looking at it this way, if
the two branching programs were
equivalent, then,
certainly, they're
always going to
give the same value.
So the probability that
the machine accepts
is going to be one.
And that's good
because we want for--
this is a case when
we're in the language.
We want the probability
of acceptance to be high.
And here, the probability
of acceptance is actually 1.
So it's always going to accept
when the two branching programs
were equivalent.
But what happens when the
branching programs are not
equivalent?
Now, we want the probability
of rejection to be high.
The probably of acceptance
should be very low, right?
So if they're not equivalent,
what we want-- the probability
that the machine
rejects is going
to be high if they're not
equivalent because that's
what the correct answer is.
Well, the only way the
machine is going to reject--
if it finds a
place where the two
branching programs disagree.
But those two
branching programs,
even though not equivalent,
might disagree rarely.
They might only disagree on one
input assignment out of the 2
to the n possibilities.
So these two in-equivalent
branching programs
might agree almost everywhere,
just except at one place.
And then that's enough for
them not to be equivalent.
But the problem is
that if you're just
going to do random
sampling, the likelihood
of finding that one exceptional
place where the two disagree
is very low.
You're going to have to do
an enormous number of samples
before you're likely to find
that point of difference.
And so in order to be
confident that you're
going to find that
difference, if there is one,
you're going to have to do
exponentially many samples.
And you don't have time to do
that with a polynomial time
algorithm.
You're just going to have
to flip too many coins.
You have to run too
many different samples,
different assignments
through these two machines.
And because they're different,
but they're almost the same.
So we're going to need to
find a different method.
And the idea is
we're going to run
these two branching
programs in some crazy way.
Instead of running them
on 0's and 1's that we've
been doing it so
far, we're going
to feed in values for
the variables which
are non-Boolean.
They are going to be--
we're going to set x1
to 2, x3 to 7, x4 to 15.
Of course, that doesn't
seem to make any sense.
But it's nevertheless going to
turn out to be a useful thing
to do, and it's going
to give us some insight
into the equivalence
or in-equivalence
of these branching programs.
OK, so let's just--
I think-- are we at the end of?
Yeah, we're at the break here.
So I'm getting some questions
coming in, which is great.
I will answer those questions.
But why don't I start
off our break and then--
OK.
OK, so there's a question
about whether this machine runs
deterministically or not.
So which machine are
we talking about?
So the branching
programs themselves,
they run deterministically.
You give them an assignment
to the input variables
that's going to determine a path
through each branching program,
which is eventually going
to output a 0 or a 1.
And you want to know, do those
two branching programs always
give the same value no
matter what the input was?
But the branching programs
themselves were deterministic.
Now the machine
that's trying to make
the determination of whether
those two branching programs
are equivalent, that machine
that we're going to be arguing
is going to be a
probabilistic machine.
So it's a kind of
non-deterministic machine
that's going to have different
possible ways to go depending
upon the outcome
of its coin tosses.
So you can think of
as non-determinism
in the ordinary sense, that it
has a tree of possibilities.
But now the way we're thinking
about acceptance is different.
Instead of accepting, if
there's just one accept branch,
the machine, for
it to accept, has
to have a majority of the
branches be accepting.
And so there's some similarities
but some differences
with the usual way we
think of non-determinism.
So what's the motivation
behind introducing
this type of Turing machine?
Well, I mean, I guess
there are two motivations.
Probabilistic algorithms,
sometimes called Monte Carlo
algorithms, turn out to
be useful in practice
for a variety of things.
And so that led to people
to think about them
in the context of complexity.
They're related in some
ways to quantum computers,
which are also probabilistic
in a somewhat different way.
But they also have a
very nice formulation
in complexity theory.
So complexity
theorists like to think
about probabilistic
computation because, I mean,
you can do interesting things
with probabilistic machines.
And the complexity
classes associated
are also interesting.
So as you'll see, it leads us
in an interesting direction
to consider how to
solve this problem,
this read-once branching
program problem equivalence
with a probabilistic machine.
It's just an
interesting algorithm
that we're going
to come up with.
So in our proof
attempt, where did we
use the probabilistic
nature for BPP?
Because we're running the
two branching programs
on a random input.
I mean, so you have your
two branching programs.
You pick a random input to run
those two branching programs,
and you see what they do.
That's why it's probabilistic.
When you think about random
behavior of the machine,
that's a probabilistic machine.
So each branch of
the machine is going
to be like the way we normally
think about non-determinism.
Somebody is asking
whether we think
of the complexity of
the machine in terms
of all of the branches of
the machine or each branch
separately.
We always think about, for
non-deterministic machines,
each branch separately.
I'm not totally sure.
I understand the question there.
So are all the inputs
built-in, and we randomly
choose one through coin flips?
Not sure I understand
that question either.
We're given as input the
two branching programs.
And then we flip coins
using our non-determinism--
you can think about
it equivalent in terms
of coin flips--
to choose the values
of the variables.
So now, we have a set
of variable inputs
to the values of the variables.
And we use that as input
to the branching programs
to see whether they--
to see what answers they
give, and, in particular,
whether they give
the same answer
on that randomly-chosen input.
Let's move on.
All right, so now moving us
toward the actual BPP algorithm
for read-once branching
program equivalence testing,
we have to think about
a different way to--
we need an alternate way of
thinking about the computation
of a branching program.
It's going to look
very similar, but it's
going to lead us in
a direction that's
going to allow us to talk
about these non-Boolean inputs
that I referred to.
Just kind of where
we're going-- we're
going to be simulating
branching programs
with polynomials, if that helps
you as an overarching plan.
But we'll get there
a little slowly.
So OK, here's a read-once
branching program.
We're not going to use the
read-once feature just yet,
but that'll come later.
But anyway, here's
a branching program.
Oh, here's my branch and my--
I crashed here.
I'll start that again.
OK, so we take an
input, whatever it is,
and thinking about the
computation of the branching--
so we're not thinking about
the algorithm, right now.
We're just thinking
about branching programs
for the minute.
We're going to get back
to the algorithm later.
So the branching program
follows a path, as I indicated,
when you have a
particular input.
If x1 is 0, x2 is 1,
x3 is 1, so the output
is going to be 1 in this case.
OK?
So the way I want to think about
this a little differently is I
want to label all of the
nodes and all of the edges
with a value that
tells me whether or not
this yellow path went
through that node or edge.
It's going to be
just doing the same,
but you may think this
is no difference at all.
But I want to label all of
the things on the yellow path,
I'm going to label
them with a 1.
And all of the things that
are not on the yellow path,
I'm going to label with a 0.
So I'm trying to keep
those labels apart
from the original
branching program, which
are written in white.
These labels are
written in yellow.
But these labels have
to do with the execution
of the branching
program on an input.
So once I have an input, that's
going to determine a 1 or a 0
label for every node and edge.
Now if we want to
look at the output
from this branching program
after we have that labeling,
we only have to look at the
label of the one output node
because if that
one has a 1 on it,
that means that the path
went through that 1.
And so therefore,
the output is 1.
So I'm going to give you
another way of assigning that.
Instead of just coming
finding the path first
and then coming up with
the labeling afterward,
I'm going to give you a
different way of coming up
with that labeling, kind of
building it up inductively,
starting at the start node
and building up that labeling.
You'll see what I
mean by my example.
So if I have a
label on this node,
so I already know whether
or not the path went
through that node, label 1
means the path went through it.
Label 0 means the path
does not go through it.
That's going to tell me how to
label the two outgoing edges.
So if I've already
labeled this with a,
where a is a 0 or a 1, then
what expression should I use?
Under what circumstances
will I label--
what's the right label for
this one outgoing edge here?
Well, if a is 0, that means
we know the path did not
go through this node.
So there's no way it could
go through that a edge.
Similarly, if xi
is a 0, that means,
even if we did go
through that node,
the path would go through the
other outgoing edge and not
through this one.
So that tells us that the
Boolean expression which
describes the label of
this node in the execution
is going to be the and
of the value on the node
and the query
variable of that node.
Now think about,
what's the right way
to label the other
edge, the execution
value of the other edge?
Again, you have to have--
go through this node,
so a has to be 1.
But now, you want xi to be 0 in
order to go through that edge.
So that means it's going to
be a and the complement of xi.
OK?
So this is going to
just tell me this.
I'm writing a formula for how
we labeling these edges based
on the label of the parent node.
Similarly, if I have a bunch
of edges where I already
know the values, the labels,
the execution labels there,
let's say, so I have a1, a2,
and a3, what is the right label
to put on this node?
Well, if any one
of those is a 1,
that means the path
went through that edge.
And so therefore, it's going
to go through that node.
So that tells us that the
label to put on that node
is the or of the labels
on the incoming edges.
OK?
Questions on this?
So now this is setting
the stage for starting
to think about this
more toward polynomials
instead of using
a Boolean algebra.
So I'm getting a question-- how
do we know what the execution
path is, which nodes to label?
We're going to be
labeling all of the nodes.
So we start off
with labeling the--
did I say that here?
We start up-- I didn't
say it, but I should have.
We labeled the start node
with 1 because the path always
goes through the start node.
So without even
talking about a path,
we just label the start node 1.
Well, maybe we'll do an
example of this also.
But now, once we label
this start-- this node 1,
we have an expression
that tells us
how to label the two outgoing
edges, this edge and that edge.
And I'm doing it without knowing
the values of the variables.
I'm just making an
expression, which
is going to describe
what those labels would
be once you tell me what
the input assignment is.
OK so I'm just sort of--
it's almost like a
symbolic execution here.
I'm just writing down
the different expressions
for how to calculate what
these things should be.
Let me-- maybe this will
become clearer as we continue.
So now this is the big
idea of this proof.
We're going to use something
called arithmetization.
We're going to convert
from thinking about things
in the Boolean world to
thinking about things
in the arithmetical world,
where we have arithmetic
over integers,
let's say, for now.
So instead of ands
and ors, we're
going to be talking
about pluses and times.
And the way we're going
to make the bridge
is by showing how to simulate
the and and or operations
with the plus and
times operations.
So assuming 1 means
true and 0 means false,
if you have the expression a
and b as a Boolean expression,
we can represent that as
a times b using arithmetic
because it computes
exactly the same value when
we have the Boolean
representation
of true and false being 1 and 0.
So 1 and 1 is 1.
And 1 times 1 is 1.
And anything else--
1 and 0, 0 and 1, 0 and 0--
if you applied the
times operator,
you're going to
get the same value.
So times is very much
like and in this sense.
OK, we're going to
write it as just ab,
usually, without
the time symbol.
So if we have a
complement, how would we
simulate that with arithmetic?
Well, again, here we're
just flipping one and 0
in using the complement
operation that's
going to be the
same as subtracting
the value from one that also
flips it from between 1 and 0.
How about or-- if
you have a or b?
Well, it's slightly
more complicated
because you use
a plus b, but you
have to subtract off
the product because what
you want is this
simulation should give you
exactly the same value.
So if you have 1 or 1, you
want that to be a 1 answer.
You don't want it to be a 2.
So you have to subtract
off the product.
And the goal is to have a
faithful simulation of the and
or by using plus and times.
So you get exactly
the same answers out
when you put in
Boolean values here.
OK, so just to say where we're
going, what this is going to--
superficially, we haven't
really done anything.
But what this is going
to enable us to do
is plug in values which are
not Boolean because it doesn't
make sense to talk about--
it makes sense to
talk about 1 and 0,
but it doesn't make sense
to talk about 2 and 3.
But it does make sense
to talk about 2 times 3.
And that's going to be useful.
OK, so let's just see.
Remember that inductive
labeling procedure
that I described before,
where I gave the execution
labels on the edges depending
upon the label of the parent
node and which node, which
variable is being queried.
So if I know that this
value is an a, but now the--
OK, so I'm just
going to write this
down using arithmetic instead
of using Boolean operations.
So before, we have-- this
was a and xi, If you remember
from the previous slide.
Now what are we going to use
instead because we're going
to use this conversion here?
Instead of and, we're going
to use multiplication.
That's just a times xi.
What about on this side?
Here was and a and
the complement of xi.
Now the complement of xi is
1 minus xi arithmetically.
So this becomes a
times 1 minus xi, OK?
Similarly, here, we did the or
to get the label on the node
from the labels of
its incoming edges.
Now, we're going do something
a little strange because we
have a formula here for or.
But for technical reasons
that will come up later,
this is not a convenient
representation for us.
What I'm going to use
instead of this one--
I'm just going to simply
say, let's take the sum.
Why is that good enough?
In this case, this
is still going
to be a faithful representation
and give the right answer all
of the time.
And that's because for
our branching programs,
read-once or otherwise,
read-once is not coming in yet,
for our branching
programs, they're acyclic.
So they can never enter a
node on two different paths.
There's, at most, one way to
come into a node on a path
through the-- on
an execution path
through the branching program.
If it comes in
through this edge,
there's no way for this edge to
also have a path because that
means you have to go out
and come back and have
a cycle in the branching
program, which is disallowed.
So at most, one
of these edges can
have the path go through it.
So at most, one of
these a's can be a 1.
The others are going to be 0.
And therefore,
just taking the sum
is going to give us a
value of either 0 or 1,
but it's never going
to give a value higher.
And so you don't
have to subtract off
these product terms.
A little bit complicated here.
If you didn't totally get
that, don't worry for now.
We're more concerned that you
get the big picture of what's
going on.
OK, so I think we're almost--
let me just see how far we are.
Yeah.
So I'm just going to
work through an example.
And I think that'll bring us--
let's just see, Do we
have any questions here?
Not seeing any.
That means you're either
all totally understanding,
or you're totally lost.
I never can tell.
So feel free to ask a question,
even if you're confused.
I'll do my best.
OK, maybe this
example might help.
So now, what we're
going to do is,
using this arithmetical view of
the way a branching program's
computation is executed
when we're running
an input through
it, this is going
to allow us now
to give a meaning
to running the branching
program on non-Boolean inputs.
So maybe this example
will illustrate that.
So let's just take this
particular branching program
here, OK?
This branching program it's just
on two variables, x1 and x2,
and it actually computes
a familiar function.
This is the
exclusive or function
if you look at it for a minute.
You'll see that this is going
to give you x1 exclusive or x2.
So it's going to be 1 if
either of the x1 or x2 are 1,
but it's going to be
0 if they're both 1.
That's what this branching
program computes.
Now, but let's take a look at
running this branching program
instead of on the
usual Boolean values,
let's run it on x1 equal
to 2 and x2 equal to 3.
Now a common confusion might
be that you're looking--
when you do the x1
query, you're looking
for another outgoing
edge, which is labeled 2.
No, that's not what I'm doing.
What I'm doing here
is, I'm somehow,
through this execution, by
assigning these other values,
I'm blending together
the computation
of x1 equal to 0 and
x1 equal to 1 together.
I don't know if that
makes any sense.
But let's look
through the example.
So first of all, these
are the labeling rules
that I had from
the previous slide
when I used plus and times
instead of and and or, OK?
Now, I'm going to
show you how to use
that to label the nodes
and edges of this graph
based on this input.
And that will determine
an output would
be the value on the 1 node.
OK, so we always start out
by labeling the start with 1.
That's just a rule.
And OK, sorry.
Let's think about it together
before I blurt out the answer.
What's going to be the
label on this edge?
So this is one of the outgoing
edges from a node that
already has a label.
So that's going to
be this case, here.
And what we do is if we
take the label of that node,
and since it's a 1
edge that's outgoing,
we multiply that
label by the value
of that variable of the
assignment to that variable.
So x1 is 2.
So we take-- the a here is 1.
x1 is assigned to 2.
So it's going to be 1 times 2
is going to be the execution
value we put on this edge.
So it's going to be 2.
What's going to be the value
we put on the other edge, the 0
outgoing edge from x1?
So I want you to think
about that for a second.
So now, we're going to
use this expression.
It's a times 1 minus xi.
And so xi, again, is 2.
So 1 minus xi is 1 minus 2.
That's how compliment--
OK, well, let's save that.
So it's 1 minus 2.
So that's minus 1
times the label 1 here.
So you get minus 1 is
the label on this edge.
Now keep in mind that
if I had plugged in--
and this is very important-- if
I had plugged in Boolean values
here, I would be getting
out the same Boolean
values that you would get just
by following through the path.
The things on the
path would be 1.
The things off the
path would be 0.
But what's happening here
is that there's still
a meaning when the
inputs are not Boolean.
So let's continue here.
How about-- what's going to
be the value on this node?
So think with me.
I think it'll help you.
So now, we're using
this rule here.
We add up all the values
on the incoming edges.
There's only one incoming
edge, which is value 2.
So that means this guy
is going to get a 2.
And similar on this one.
This guy is going
to get a minus 1.
Now, let's take a
look at this edge.
So this is the 0 outgoing
edge from a node labeled 2
with label x2.
So this is the 0 outgoing edge.
The label is 2, so
it's going to be
2 times 1 minus the x2 value.
x2 is 3.
So 1 minus 3 is minus 2.
It's going to be 2 times
minus 2, which is minus 4.
So similarly, you can
get the value here,
the value on the
one outgoing edge
is going to be 2 times
the x2 value, which is 3,
so that's going to be 6.
And these two here--
so now, we have a minus 1.
And the outgoing is a 0
edge, so it's 1 minus 3.
And here, it's going
to be 1 times minus 3.
No.
1 times 3.
I'm sorry.
The answer's minus 3.
So now what's the label
on the 0 output edge?
So you have to aid up the
two incoming edges here.
So we have this
edge here was a 2.
This edge coming in here is a
6, so it's going to be 2 plus 6.
It's 8.
What about this edge--
this node here?
This is an important
node because this
is going to be the output.
So it has minus 3 coming
in and a minus 4 coming in,
so you add those together.
You get a minus 7.
I mean, you may wonder, what--
[LAUGHS] what in the
world is going on here?
Is this a lot of mumbo jumbo?
But we're going to make sense
of all this-- not today.
We're going to have
to argue why this is--
what the meaning that
we're going to get out
of this is going to be.
But the point is that
this is going to lead
to a new algorithm for testing.
This is, again, getting
back to what we were doing.
This is the
equivalence problem for
read-once branching programs.
So now, what the new
algorithm is going to do
is going to pick a random
non-Boolean assignment.
So it's going to
randomly assign values
to the x's and to some
non-Boolean values.
Instead of zeros and
ones, we're going
to plug in random
integer values.
We'll make that clear next time
what the domain is going to be.
And then once we have that
non-Boolean assignment,
we're going to value B1 and B2.
And if they disagree out
there in that extended domain,
then we have to show that
they're not equivalent,
and then we'll reject.
And we'll also show that if
they were equivalent, then even
when we evaluate them, we have
to show that if they're not
equivalent, that they're
very likely to have
a difference in the
non-Boolean domain.
And so if they agree,
it gives you evidence
that the two are
really equivalent.
So the completeness proof
will come after Thanksgiving.
So with that, I'm going to
wish you all a nice break.
Oh, we have a check-in here.
Sorry.
Oh, yeah, this is a good one.
I don't know if you're following
me, but if I plug in 1 for x1
and y for x2--
do the inputs in the
assignment need to be distinct?
No.
It could be the same value.
I could be 2 and 2 here.
That's perfectly valid.
But here, I'm going
to plug in 1 for x1,
and I'm going to plug
in a variable for x2--
y.
And I'm going to do the whole
calculation that I just did.
And now, what's going
to be the output?
And I mean, this looks
like a pain to figure out.
You could do it.
It looks like a pain.
But let me give you a big hint.
Remember that this thing is
supposed to be calculating.
The original branching program
calculates the exclusive
or function.
And that means when I
plug in a Boolean value,
I should get the exclusive
or value coming out.
So if I already know that
x1 is 1, which of these
is consistent with
getting a value
that the exclusive or
function would compute?
So let me launch a poll on that.
So we're out of time.
So let's just let this run
for another 10 seconds.
OK, I'm going to close this.
Ready?
Yes, indeed, a is
the right answer
because that's one-- if I know
that one variable is 1, then
the exclusive or is going
to be the complement
of the other variable,
which is 1 minus y.
So that's what you would
get if you calculated this.
OK, so this is
what we did today.
And feel free to ask questions.
So we're going to
spend a good chunk--
I'll review this, what
we've done so far,
but then we're going to
carry it forward and spend
a good chunk of
Tuesday's lecture
after the Thanksgiving
break proving
that this procedure that I just
described worked and works.
And it's an interesting
but somewhat--
it's not such an easy proof.
So we're going to spend--
try to do it slowly and clearly.
But this notion
of arithmetization
is going to be--
it's an important
notion in complexity.
And so we'll see it again coming
up in another proof afterward
about interactive proof systems.
OK, so please ask questions.
So the output is the value
of the output 1 state, yes.
There was a question I got.
Other questions?
Somebody saying, minus 7
is not the XOR of 2 and 2.
[LAUGHS] What is
the XOR of 2 and 3?
So by the way, I should say,
we kind of ran a little short
on time, I'm not saying
that we discovered
some fundamental new
truth about XOR here
because that would be bizarre.
It really depends on
the arbitrary decision
that we made to say true
is 1 and false is 0.
We could have come up with
a different representation
for true and false.
And then you would
get a different value
for XOR coming out of that--
from the arithmetization
that I just described.
But for this particular way of
representing true and false,
that's how XOR and this
particular branching program,
that's how XOR evaluates.
The remainder of the proof--
so somebody is
asking, which is true,
the fundamental
theorem of algebra,
which talks about polynomials
and the number of routes
that you can have--
that's going to be critical.
So that is the fundamental
theorem of algebra.
That's where we're going.
Good question.
Somebody is complaining
that we're not
taking the digit binary
representation of 2 and 3
and taking the bit by bit XOR.
Binary representation
is not a part of this.
We're thinking of these as two
elements of a finite field,
which we'll talk about later.
The binary representation is not
entering into this discussion.
So I'll talk about why just
doing the sum is enough.
I think that was--
so why is it--
I mean, here it is.
Why is just doing
the sum when I'm
looking at how to describe
the value of this node
based upon the values of
all the incoming nodes.
And remember, the
starting point of this
is that we have to faithfully
represent the Boolean
logic with the arithmetic.
And then we're going to
use that and extend it
to non-Boolean values.
But as a starting point, we
have to faithfully represent
the Boolean values.
Now the Boolean values,
on the incoming edges,
at most, one of them can
be a 1 because the 1's
correspond to the edges
of the execution path.
And you can't make an
execution path that's
going to have two branches--
that's going to
go through a node
twice because then
you have a loop.
And we don't have--
there's no cycles allowed.
OK, so I think
we're-- it's at 4:00.
I want to say
farewell to you all.
Have a great week.
And I'll see you
when you get back.